I remember hearing Jagged Little Pill
back in my 20s and the fact that I knew
that some of the songs by alas were
personal experiences he made me like for
even more as an artist so turning the
tables and becoming a fan to someone
does that help you like an artist more
once you know
that something very very personal was
actually part of their own life and they
were willing to admit a defeat probably
probably I think of course when someone
lets down their guard like that
and they're singing lyrics like Lana
s'mores at sang I'm Jagged Little Pill
you have to go whoa that person is
owning every horrible thing that like
happened to them and some of that those
things you can't invent you almost know
someone had to experience that because
it sounds so believable you know I'm
happy really all right now you ought to
know yeah absolutely you oughta know and
them and you know in the theater you
know everyone knows that and yeah and I
think ya know it does ingratiate that
person to you by knowing Oh like and
really owning her experience and I think
it makes you like her you know makes you
identify with that it's like oh ok a lot
of s'mores that's gone through some
tough times and I have to that's cool I
don't know there's something like a
kinship that forms in a moment like that
when you know the song is is real and
was inspired by something
not just something she invented yet
you